I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey gang, how's it going? Howdy! It is Weight Loss Part 2. Season 5. Yeah, this is the second part of our Season 5 premiere. It was written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky and directed by Paul Feig. Hit us with a summary. All right. Well, you might remember last week we set up that Dunder Mifflin is doing a company-wide
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。嘿，大家伙，最近怎么样？嗨！这是《减肥》第二部分。第五季。是的，这是我们第五季首播的第二部分。由李·艾森伯格和让·斯特普尼斯基编剧，保罗·费格执导。给我们来个总结。好的。好吧，你可能还记得上周我们提到邓德米夫林正在举办一场全公司范围的
weight loss contest. That contest continues. It's really causing some division among the employees. People are getting angry. They are. Ryan returns to Scranton. He's a temp again. Michael hires him to fill in at reception for Pam, who is off at Pratt. She's, you know, doing art school. Now Michael is very slowly, still pursuing Holly. Dwight and Angela are continuing to hook up in the warehouse behind Andy's back. And Jim has an important question for Pam. The question! All right. Fast fact number one. Paul Feig directed this episode and he also had a much larger role overall in Season 5. Paul was with us for every single episode of Season 5. He was, and he was amazing. He was this great constant, like, I don't
减肥比赛。比赛仍在继续。这确实在员工中引起了一些分歧。大家开始生气了。确实如此。瑞安回到了斯克兰顿。他又成临时工了。迈克尔雇他在前台顶替去了普瑞特学院的帕姆。她呢，你知道的，在学艺术。现在迈克尔依然非常缓慢地在追求霍莉。德怀特和安吉拉继续在安迪不知情的情况下在仓库里偷情。吉姆有一个重要问题要问帕姆。这个问题！好的。趣味事实一。保罗·费格执导了这一集，他在第五季中也扮演了更重要的整体角色。保罗陪伴我们度过了第五季的每一集。确实如此，而且他太棒了。他就像是一个伟大的定海神针，就像，我不
know, Jim. He was like the man of the ship. He was like guiding us along the way. And having him on set always just made me feel better. I'm with you. I loved it. You remember last week we talked about how Greg Daniels was now working on both the office and he was trying to get Parks and Rec off the ground. He had groomed Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein to run the show. They were overseeing the writing of the show. They were running the writer's room. Well, Paul Feig was brought on as a supervising director and co-executive producer to oversee the on set production and to oversee all of our directors. Because we had a lot of new directors in Season 5, including some cast members and crew members
知道，吉姆。他就像是这艘船的掌舵人。他就像是一路引领着我们。有他在片场总是让我感觉更好。我懂你。我也超喜欢。你还记得上周我们讨论过格雷格·丹尼尔斯现在既要忙《办公室》，又要努力让《公园与游憩》开播。他培养了詹·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦来运营这部剧。他们负责监督该剧的编剧工作。他们管理着编剧室。好吧，保罗·费格被请来担任总导演兼联合执行制片人，以监督现场制作并管理我们所有的导演。因为我们在第五季中有很多新导演，包括一些演员和剧组人员
and even some of our writers. They all directed their first episodes. Paul was also in the writer's room a bit, but mostly he was like the taste maker, right? He was like one of these original visionaries. What is the taste maker? I mean, I don't know, but I think a taste maker is like you set the tastes of... Did you make up that word? No, taste maker is a real word. Well, maybe if you're like running a winery. But you can be like a taste maker like is the same as like a... I think you made it up. Well, I didn't. You can Google it. I can't believe you're getting out your phone right now to Google it. This is unbelievable. Taste maker is a real word. It's like a trend setter. Yes. Thank you, Sam. It's like a trend
甚至还有我们的一些编剧。他们都执导了自己的第一集。保罗也偶尔待在编剧室里，但大多数时候他就像是品味引领者，对吧？他就像是那些最初的远见者之一。什么是品味引领者？我的意思是，我不知道，但我觉得品味引领者就像是你设定了……这个词是你编的吗？不对，品味引领者是个真词。好吧，也许如果你是在经营一家酒庄的话。但你也可以成为品味引领者，就像……我觉得是你编的。才没有。你可以谷歌一下。真不敢相信你现在拿手机出来谷歌。这太不可思议了。品味引领者是个真词。就像是潮流引领者。是的。谢谢你，萨姆。就像是潮流
setter. Okay. Taste maker. Okay. According to the English language learner's definition, a person whose judgment about what is good, fashionable, etc. are accepted and followed by many other people. That's right. He was a taste maker. He was a taste maker. He was. It was his job to control the quality of the show. If you know, he said yes to jokes and no to other jokes because of his good taste. I know this is getting us off so early. I really want to know the origin of this word. Like where did the word taste maker come from? Was it the person that like tried the food for the king and if he didn't die? Okay, fine. We'll all eat what that guy had. I don't know, but I think you should deep dive it for a
引领者。好的。品味引领者。好吧。根据英语学习者词典的定义，一个人的判断力——关于什么是好的、时尚的等——被许多其他人接受并追随。没毛病。他就是品味引领者。他就是品味引领者。他确实是。他的工作就是控制节目的质量。如果，你知道的，他因为自己出色的品味对某些笑话说了“行”，对另一些笑话说了“不行”。我知道这让我们从一开始就扯远了。我真的很想知道这个词的起源。比如“品味引领者”这个词是从哪来的？是不是那种帮国王试毒，如果没死的话……好吧，行吧。那我们就吃那家伙吃过的东西。我不知道，但我觉得你应该为安吉拉的重温节目深入研究一下
revisit of Angela. Okay, fine. I do. Okay. Paul Feig was the taste maker. Well, listen. I talked to Greg Daniels about it and he said that this was a big push that he had to make with the network. In particular, Jerry DeCanio, the head of production at Universal, because our show had been functioning just fine without someone in this role before. But Greg explained he was often called down to set to discuss the shooting or the motivations with the actors and directors. And he wanted to make sure that that would still be covered while he was gone. And they eventually agreed. And I traded some messages with Paul Feig about this too. And he even sent in an audio clip. Oh, Paul Feig all the way from London. Yep.
好吧，行吧。我觉得也是。好吧。保罗·费格就是品味引领者。听着。我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯聊过这件事，他说这是他不得不与电视网进行的一次艰难争取。特别是环球影城的制作负责人杰瑞·德卡尼奥，因为在此之前，我们的剧在没有这个职位的情况下也一直运转良好。但格雷格解释说，他经常被叫到片场去和演员、导演讨论拍摄或动机。他想确保在他离开期间这些方面仍然能兼顾到。他们最终同意了。我和保罗·费格也关于此事互发了一些信息。他甚至还发来了一段音频片段。哦，保罗·费格远在伦敦。没错。
It was such a fun year because, you know, to be around you guys in the cast every day and to be in that writer's room with that amazing group of writers was just such a special opportunity. Yeah, I got to direct a lot of episodes that season, but also it was just fun to kind of be with all these other people who were starting to direct and seeing how great they were doing. It was so fun to be with Steve when he directed his first episode and Brent Forrester did a great job and Dave Rogers, we had so much fun. And so that was kind of my experience of the fifth season was being around everybody so much, but also just kind of getting to see the show through a lot of fresh eyes of these new directors or people coming on and doing it for the first time.
这一年真的太有趣了，因为，你知道的，每天能和你们这些演员在一起，能和那群优秀的编剧一起待在编剧室里，真的是一次非常特别的机会。是的，那个季度我执导了很多集，但同时，能和所有这些开始执导的新人在一起，看他们做得多么出色，也觉得很有趣。能和史蒂夫在一起看着他执导他的第一集真是太有趣了，布伦特·福斯特做得很好，还有戴夫·罗杰斯，我们玩得太开心了。所以这就是我经历的第五季——和大家在一起度过很多时光，同时也通过这些新导演或第一次尝试执导的人们的崭新视角来看待这部剧。
Well, I want to say that Paul also directed five episodes himself this season. Hmm. And when we were trading messages, Angela, he said he loved his time on season five so much that he wanted to send us audio clips for every single episode of season five. Get out! Paulopedia! Paulopedia! I was like, Paul, you're busy. You're directing a movie right now in London. I mean, you don't have to do that. And he said, well, I'll do as many as I can. So guys, get ready. Get ready for, should it be, Figopedia or Paulopedia? Paulfigopedia? Paulfigopedia! All right. Fast fact number two is an art school location breakdown. We didn't do this last week.
嗯，我想说保罗这一季自己也执导了五集。嗯。当我们互发信息时，安吉拉，他说他太喜欢第五季的时光了，以至于他想为第五季的每一集都给我们发音频片段。开玩笑道！保罗百科全书！保罗百科全书！我当时就想，保罗，你很忙。你现在正在伦敦导演一部电影。我的意思是，你用不着这么做。他说，好吧，我能做多少就做多少。所以大家，准备好。准备好迎接，这该叫什么，费格百科全书还是保罗百科全书？保罗·费格百科全书？保罗·费格百科全书！好的。趣味事实二是一份艺术学校取景地剖析。我们上周没做这个。
We're going to see more of art school this week. So I thought it was appropriate. Okay. Fan question from Yvette and Rachel. Where were the New York City art school scenes shot? I will tell you. Everything was shot at USC, the University of Southern California. The classrooms were empty classrooms on campus that our set decorators dressed. Even the dorm room was a USC dorm room. The hallways, when Jim's watching TV in the common room, we were basically all on campus. The only thing we didn't do on campus, and we talked about this last week, was when Jim and Pam are video chatting. They recreated my dorm room on that warehouse set of Dunder Mifflin. Well, I have one other thing to share about the USC campus,
这周我们会看到更多艺术学校的场景。所以我认为这很合适。好的。伊韦特和雷切尔的粉丝提问。纽约市的艺术学校场景是在哪里拍摄的？我来告诉你。所有场景都是在USC，也就是南加州大学拍摄的。教室是校园里我们布景师进行过装饰的空教室。就连宿舍也是南加州大学的宿舍。走廊，当吉姆在休息室看电视时，我们基本上全都在校园里。唯一没有在校园里拍的，我们上周也聊过，就是吉姆和帕姆视频通话的那场戏。我们在邓德米夫林的那个仓库片场重建了我的宿舍。好吧，关于南加州大学校园我还有另一件事要分享，
but I am going to save it when it comes up in the episode. Well, all right. I have one fun thing to share about the real Pratt, which is in Brooklyn. That's where Pam's meant to be. We got a letter from Mila S, who is a student at Pratt, and she said this. There is a communal cat population living on campus called Pratt Cats. They have their own little houses, and they wander the lecture halls and the campus freely. If you're ever in New York after COVID, I highly recommend you visit the campus, along with its sculptures and cats roaming the grounds. Angela, the cats even have their own Instagram page, and it's called Pratt Cats. Pratt Cats? That's so cute. Two T's for Pratt and two T's for Cats.
但我打算等到剧集播到那里时再说。好吧，好吧。关于真正的普瑞特学院，我有一件趣事要分享，它在布鲁克林。那是帕姆应该去的地方。我们收到了一封来自米拉·S的信，她是普瑞特的学生，她是这么写的。校园里生活着一群被称为“普瑞特猫”的社区猫。它们有自己的小房子，在演讲厅和校园里自由漫步。如果你在疫情后去过纽约，我强烈建议你去参观一下校园，还有那里随处游荡的雕塑和猫咪。安吉拉，这些猫甚至还有自己的Instagram主页，名字就叫“普瑞特猫”。普瑞特猫？太可爱了吧。普瑞特（Pratt）两个T，猫（Cats）两个T。
Pratt Cats. Pratt Cats. I looked at it. It's just a lot of super cute pictures of cats. I want to see it. Oh my gosh. There's so many. Yeah. There's so many cats. I think we should put this on our list. We should. All right. Fast fact number three. We've got a big guest star alert. It's Rich Summer as Pam's art school friend, Alex. Yes. And we are friends with Rich. We're like really good friends with Rich. He needs to come on. Well, he's refused. No, he has not. Kidding. We are going to have him on. You guys, Rich is probably most well known for his role as Harry Crane on Mad Men, but he's also acted in such shows as Wet Hot American Summer, the TV series, as well as many movies with office connections. Oh yeah. He was in The
普瑞特猫。普瑞特猫。我看过了。上面全都是超级可爱的猫咪照片。我想看。哦天哪。有好多呀。对啊。有超多猫。我觉得我们应该把这个列入我们的愿望清单。必须的。好的。趣味事实三。我们迎来了大牌客串明星预告。里奇·萨莫饰演帕姆在艺术学校的朋友亚历克斯。是的。而且我们和里奇是朋友。我们和里奇真的是好朋友。他该来节目作客了。好吧，他拒绝了。不，他没有。开玩笑的。我们一定会请他来的。伙计们，里奇最著名的角色可能是在《广告狂热》中扮演的哈里·克朗，但他还出演过诸如《湿热的美国夏天》（电视剧版）等剧集，以及许多与《办公室》有渊源的电影。哦，对。他出演了
Devil Wears Prada starring Emily Blunt. He was in Celeste and Jesse Forever starring Rashida Jones, and he was in The Giant Mechanical Man starring me. Yay. He is also supposedly real life friends with Nicholas DeGosto, a.k.a. Hunter. We're going to have to ask him about that when he comes on the show. Oh yeah. We have lots to ask him. We do. Jenna, as you remember from last week, there is a fantastic DVD commentary for Weight Loss. It's an all-crew DVD commentary. I have more to share from that in this week's Weight Loss Part 2, as well as I reached out to Joya Balfour. Do you guys remember Joya? She has contributed information on the podcast before. She worked on the digital team at NBC.com, and she has some fun Andy-Angela wedding stuff that
由艾米莉·布朗特主演的《穿普拉达的女王》。他出演了由拉什达·琼斯主演的《萍水相逢的我们》，他还出演了由我主演的《宏伟机械师》。耶。据说他和尼古拉斯·达戈斯托（也就是亨特）在现实生活中也是朋友。等他来节目的时候，我们得问问他这件事。哦，对。我们有很多问题要问他。确实如此。詹娜，正如你从上周所记得的那样，关于《减肥》有一段精彩的DVD评论音轨。那是一段全剧组的DVD评论音轨。关于这周的《减肥》第二部分，我还有更多内容要分享，此外我还联系了乔雅·巴尔福。大家还记得乔雅吗？她以前曾为播客提供过信息。她在NBC.com的数字团队工作，她有一些关于安迪和安吉拉婚礼的趣事
she shared with me, as well as one little surprise, but we'll get to it. I love it. Should we take a break, and then we'll be back? Yeah. We are back, and a friendly Ryan has returned to Dunder Mifflin Scranton. There is a deleted scene, Jenna, that the camera catches Ryan being dropped off to work by his mother. She's driving a station wagon. She pulls up. He hops out with a little sack lunch, and he starts to go in the building, and she rolls down the window and honks her horn, and he runs back and gives her a kiss on the cheek, and then he runs in the building. Wow. If this tells you where Ryan is at at life, he's back living at home, and his mom is driving him
她分享给了我，还有一个小惊喜，不过我们待会儿再聊。太棒了。我们要不要休息一下，然后回来？好的。我们回来了，一个态度友好的瑞安回到了斯克兰顿邓德米夫林。詹娜，有一个被删减的片段，镜头捕捉到瑞安由他妈妈开车送到公司。她开着一辆旅行车。车停了下来。他带着一个小纸袋午餐跳下车，开始往大楼里走，然后她摇下车窗按了按喇叭，他又跑回去在她脸颊上亲了一下，接着才跑进大楼。哇。如果这能说明瑞安目前的生活状态的话，那就是他又搬回家住了，他妈还开车送他
to work. Wow. He's also grown a goatee, and this now explains why Michael has had a goatee, because he says, Michael, did you grow that goatee after you saw mine when you helped me move? Remember, these goatees are not real. Hair and makeup put them on. I thought they did a fantastic job, and Michael has a talking head that explains that he hired Ryan off the temp agency. Yeah. He said Ronnie was very blech, and he told the temp agency, I don't care what it costs me, I have to have him. I have to have Ryan Howard. People don't know how to react to Ryan being back. Kevin is excited, runs over, gives him a noogie, which starts a great runner, and Jenna, there was more in the deleted scenes of Ryan
上班。哇。他还留了山羊胡，这现在解释了为什么迈克尔也留了山羊胡，因为他说：迈克尔，你这山羊胡是不是看到我帮我搬家时留的胡子后才留的？记住，这些山羊胡都是假的。发型和化妆部门给贴上的。我觉得他们做得太棒了，迈克尔有一个单人访谈，解释了他通过临时工介绍所雇用了瑞安。对。他说罗尼太逊了，他告诉临时工介绍所，不管花多少钱，我都必须得到他。我必须得到瑞安·霍华德。大家不知道该如何应对瑞安的回归。凯文很兴奋，跑过去给他来了个锁喉揉头，这就开启了一条很棒的支线剧情，詹娜，被删减片段里还有更多瑞安的单人访谈
having these talking heads, where he's putting everyone who's wronged him on his list. Yeah. He explains that he's making a list so that when he is back up on the top, he can get his revenge. Yeah, and Kevin just made the list. Also, who makes the list is David Wallace. In a deleted scene, David Wallace calls, Ryan answers, and David flips out, starts braiding Ryan. You can hear it through the phone. Yeah. So much so that Ryan cries, and Michael vouches for Ryan, and David Wallace does not want him there, but agrees. And so now David Wallace has made the list, and Jenna, I couldn't help myself. You know what this made me think of. What? Game of thrones. Oh, somebody has a list I didn't get that far.
他在访谈中把所有得罪过他的人都记在了他的复仇小本本上。对。他解释说他正在记名单，这样等他东山再起时，就可以去报复了。对，而凯文刚刚上了黑名单。另外，上榜的还有大卫·华莱士。在一个被删减的片段中，大卫·华莱士打来电话，瑞安接了电话，大卫气炸了，开始把瑞安骂得狗血淋头。你通过电话都能听到。对。以至于瑞安都哭了，迈克尔为瑞安说好话，而大卫·华莱士根本不想他在那儿，但还是同意了。所以现在大卫·华莱士也上了黑名单，詹娜，我真的控制不住自己。你知道这让我想起了什么吗？什么？《权力的游戏》。哦，有人有个黑名单我还没看到那儿。
Arya Stark has a kill list for everyone who's wronged her. Can we take a minute, everybody, if you haven't seen Game of Thrones and you don't want spoilers? Just, I don't know, fast forward 30 seconds. Angela. What? I started Game of Thrones. I never finished it. I'm never going to finish it. Really? Will you just tell me, does Arya ever kill? She f***ing kills everybody. She does. She kills everybody, and she kills the biggest baddie, and I don't want to ruin it in case someone didn't fast forward, but she kind of saves the whole world. I'll just say that. That is kind of a spoiler. That was the only thing that was kind of keeping me there, was that I saw the potential in her character. No, she follows through. Well, that's good to know.
艾莉亚·斯塔克有一份复仇死亡名单，上面记着所有得罪过她的人。大家，如果有人还没看过《权力的游戏》而且不想被剧透的话，我们能花一分钟时间吗？那就，我不知道，快进30秒吧。安吉拉。什么？我开始看《权力的游戏》了。我从来没看完过。我永远也看不完了。真的吗？你能不能告诉我，艾莉亚最后杀人了吗？她特么把所有人都杀了。真的。她把所有人都杀了，她还杀了最大的恶人，我不想剧透，万一有人没快进的话，但她算是拯救了全世界。我只能说这么多。这某种程度上算是剧透了。唯一能留住我的就是我看到了她角色的潜力。不，她说到做到。好吧，这倒是个好消息。
Continuing Ryan's list, Ryan apologizes to Jim, right? Jim shakes his hand, and now are you ready for some Jim sass? Oh, it's so good though. Ready? Ryan says, Jim, I want to apologize for how I treated you last year. He goes on to explain all the things he feels sorry for, and he said, you know, he's even started volunteering. He's giving back to the community. And Jim goes, well, that's great. You're talking about your court ordered community service. And Ryan says, I don't need a judge to tell me to keep my community clean. And then Jim goes, but he did, right? And Ryan goes, all right. And Jim goes, all right. So much Jim sass. And then there's just a silent Ryan talking head where he's staring down the lens of the camera, and he's clearly writing
接着说瑞安的黑名单，瑞安向吉姆道歉了，对吧？吉姆跟她握了手，现在你们准备好迎接吉姆的毒舌了吗？哦，不过真的太精彩了。准备好了吗？瑞安说：吉姆，我想为我去年对你的态度向你道歉。他接着解释了他所有感到抱歉的事情，他说，你知道的，他甚至开始做志愿者了。他在回馈社区。吉姆说：哦，那太棒了。你是说你那法庭判决的社区服务令吗？瑞安说：我才不需要法官来告诉我要保持社区清洁。然后吉姆说：但法官确实这么说了，对吧？瑞安说：好吧。然后吉姆说：好吧。满满的吉姆毒舌。然后是一个无声的瑞安单人访谈，他直勾勾地盯着摄像机镜头，显然是在把
Jim Halpert in his list, which I loved. It's time for another weigh in on the giant scale that was custom made for our show we learned last week. There is a zero pound weight loss. People are really starting to melt down. 22 minutes 59 seconds. Did anyone catch that Meredith's face is back to normal? Oh, I didn't catch that. No more sunburn on Meredith. I'll tell you, we had Aaron M write in and say, during that moment of the weigh in, Michael does this bird like flapping move when he's frustrated. And she says it's literally my favorite moment in the whole show. She wants to know if Steve improvised that. Yes, that was not scripted. That was Steve's take on his character's frustration. I loved it so much at 23 minutes 21 seconds. Andy has a talking
吉姆·哈尔珀特写进他的黑名单，我太喜欢了。又到了在那个为我们的节目定制的巨型秤上过称的时候了，我们上周知道了这一点。重量减轻了零磅。大家真的开始崩溃了。22分59秒。有人注意到梅雷迪思的脸恢复正常了吗？哦，我没注意到。梅雷迪思没有晒伤了。我告诉你们吧，艾伦·M发信来说，在那个过称的瞬间，迈克尔在沮丧时做了一个像鸟儿拍打翅膀一样的动作。她说这简直是整部剧里她最喜欢的时刻。她想知道这是否是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。是的，这不是剧本里的。那是史蒂夫对他的角色那种沮丧情绪的演绎。我太喜欢这个了，在23分21秒。安迪有一个单人
head. He says this is the hardest thing he's ever had to do. And you know, he hasn't had a very hard life. Ding, ding, ding. This was a digitally corrected shirt and tie. Once again, we talked about this in the episode previously weight loss one, that the writers wanted to move around some of Andy's talking heads and to match his outfits for continuity, they had to go in and post production change the color of his tie and a shirt. I mean, it just blows my mind still. I know. Some other things that happened in the scene are that Holly tells Oscar that her date went well with his yoga instructor and Michael overhears and then he blames Jim because he thinks Jim's bad advice has landed him in the friend zone with Holly. And then we move upstairs. Yeah.
访谈。他说这是他有生以来做过最难的事情。要知道，他其实没过过什么苦日子。叮，叮，叮。这是一件经过数字修正的衬衫和领带。再次强调，我们之前在《减肥》第一集里讨论过，编剧们想要调整安迪的一些单人访谈顺序，为了配合服装的连贯性，他们不得不在后期制作中改变他的领带和衬衫的颜色。我的意思是，这到现在还是让我大开眼界。我懂的。这一幕中发生的其他事情是，霍莉告诉奥斯卡她和他的瑜伽教练约会很顺利，迈克尔无意中听到了，然后他开始责怪吉姆，因为他认为吉姆糟糕的建议让他和霍莉陷入了“朋友区”。然后我们上楼去了。对。
Dwight is really mad. He doesn't think everyone's taking this seriously. He randomly selects Stanley Phyllis and Kevin and tells them to get liposuction on their own dime. Yeah, they have to pay for it. Yeah. And meanwhile, Ryan goes to apologize to Kelly. And now we have some Kelly sass. Oh, it's so satisfying. It's so good. I mean, Ryan, come on. I wish you could have stuck to it. I know. It's so good. He's like, hey, should we, you know, grab a drink later, catch up. And then he says, pick me up at eight, right? He's trying to do his old shenanigans with her. And she goes, that is so sweet. But I'm dating Darryl still and we're like crazy in love. So, and he goes, oh, cool. Well, maybe I'll see you around.
德怀特气坏了。他觉得大家都没有严肃对待这件事。他随机挑选了斯坦利、菲利斯和凯文，叫他们自掏腰包去做吸脂手术。对，他们得自己付钱。对。与此同时，瑞安去找凯莉道歉。现在我们要迎来一些凯莉的毒舌了。哦，太解气了。太精彩了。我的意思是，瑞安，拜托。我真希望你能坚持住。我知道。太精彩了。他说：嘿，我们要不要一会儿去喝一杯，叙叙旧。然后他说：八点来接我，对吧？他正试图对她故伎重施呢。然后凯莉说：太甜了。但我还在跟达里尔约会，我们爱得死去活来的。所以，然后他说：哦，酷。好吧，那也许回头见。
And Kelly goes, it's a small office. Yeah. Yeah. Did you notice on her desk? What? She had her little name plate from the first Christmas party. Yes. I did see that with the flower. I thought that was so cute. I did too. Dwight's going to apologize to Phyllis for telling her she should get liposuction on her own dime. He says, I'm going to make it up to you. I have a sale, but it requires two people. Will you go with me? Big sale. Oh, yeah. It's a short thing. Yeah. I'll give you 40%. I'll split it with you 60-40. He says he'll drive. She's like, all right. And then, of course, Kelly needs to have this really odd, forced make out session with Darryl
凯莉说：办公室就这么大。对。对。你注意到她的办公桌上了吗？什么？她摆着从第一次圣诞派对来的那个小名牌。对。我确实看到那个上面有朵花。我觉得太可爱了。我也是。德怀特要向菲利斯道歉，因为之前叫她自掏腰包去做吸脂手术。他说：我要弥补你。我有一个大单子，但需要两个人。你愿意跟我一起去吗？大单子。哦，是的。很快就能搞定。是的。我给你40%的提成。我们六四分账。他说他开车。她心想：好吧。然后，当然了，凯莉需要当着瑞安的面，故意和达里尔来一场非常古怪、极其勉强的强吻。但我得让你知道，詹娜，在26分12秒，
in front of Ryan on purpose. But I want you to know, Jenna, at 26 minutes, 12 seconds, you get a really good shot of Ryan's like his phone, earpiece, headset thingy. Yeah. Yeah. According to Randy Cordray, our line producer, there was a lengthy discussion about which ear headset Ryan should use. He said Phil Shea brought over a tray. He said it looked like 12 to 20. That sounds right. Different versions for them to pick out. That sounds about right. Yeah. They picked a real douchey one, so good job, guys. Let's go to the break room. Jim is having lunch with Michael and Holly. Two things here. Continuity catch. I don't know if you noticed, but Michael suddenly does not have a goatee.
你能看清瑞安的那个手机，呃，耳机，头戴式耳机的特写。对。对。根据我们的制片主任兰迪·科德里的说法，关于瑞安应该用哪种耳机的耳朵款式，曾有过一番冗长的讨论。他说菲尔·谢拿过来一个托盘。他说看起来有12到20种。听起来差不多。供他们挑选的不同版本。听起来确实如此。对。他们挑了一个特别混蛋款的，干得漂亮，伙计们。我们去茶水间吧。吉姆正和迈克尔、霍莉一起吃午饭。这里有两件事。连贯性穿帮。我不知道你们有没有注意到，迈克尔突然没有山羊胡了。
Oh, yes. They were having issues keeping track. And also, there are a lot of fruit flies in the vending machine. Well, lady, I think it's time for a fruit fly breakdown. Oh, please. Angela, we got a lot of mail about the fruit flies. Hit me with your questions because I have some answers. People wanted to know if they were real, were they CGI. I remember Jean Stupnitsky told me they were real and they even had a fruit fly wrangler. They were real. Let me tell you everything I learned about them in the DVD commentary. First of all, this whole bit cost thousands of dollars. All right. These fruit flies were from the Florida fruit fly growers and they were bred specifically for this episode. These type of fruit flies are a sterile type of fruit fly,
哦，对的。他们一直在为连戏焦头烂额。而且，自动售货机里有很多果蝇。好吧，女士，我觉得是时候来剖析一下果蝇了。哦，拜托。安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于果蝇的邮件。用你的问题砸向我吧，因为我有一些答案。大家想知道它们是真的还是CGI特效。我记得让·斯特普尼斯基告诉我它们是真的，他们甚至还请了一个果蝇驯养师。它们是真的。让我把我在DVD评论音轨里了解到的关于它们的一切都告诉你吧。首先，光是这个桥段就花了好几千美元。好吧。这些果蝇来自佛罗里达果蝇种植者协会，它们是专门为这一集培育的。这种果蝇是一种不育型的果蝇，
and they are bred for Florida citrus farms. According to Kelly Cantley, they have a very specific breeding cycle, so they had to schedule the fruit flies to be released on a specific day. And Randy, Randy said we had fruit flies for weeks. I remember them. I do too. We'd go in the break room and there would still be a few buzzing around. Yeah. I guess even though they couldn't mate, a lot of them, they really lived beyond their life cycle. Yeah. In addition to these fruit flies breeding schedule that we had to plan around, Jenna Filchet had to time out rotting fruit over the course of eight weeks. Oh my gosh. This fruit had to go through stages of rotting. He had a table set up on our soundstage full of fruit and different stages of rotting
它们是为佛罗里达州的柑橘农场培育的。根据凯莉·坎特利的说法，它们有非常特殊的繁殖周期，所以他们必须安排果蝇在特定的一天释放。而兰迪，兰迪说我们有整整几周都有果蝇。我还记得它们。我也记得。我们去茶水间，还是会看到有几只在周围嗡嗡叫。对。我猜尽管它们无法交配，但其中很多确实超出了它们的生命周期。对。除了我们不得不围绕其进行计划的果蝇繁殖周期外，詹娜，菲尔·谢还得在八周内掌握腐烂水果的时间。哦天哪。这些水果必须经历腐烂的各个阶段。他在我们的摄影棚里摆了一张桌子，上面满是处于不同腐烂阶段的水果
for this scene. Lady, I was just about to say that. As you said that, a memory came flooding back into my head of this giant long table where he had created little squares out of tape. Yeah. And each square had a different piece of fruit in it in different stages of rot. Yes, all for this one gag. That is like on camera for like two seconds. I know. Again, like some little throwaway line in the script created all of this production. Florida fruit fly growers, rotted fruit, fruit fly wranglers. Incredible. Shifting gears here over at Pratt. Pam is in the hallway between classes. She's palling around with her new school friends. Alex, played by Rich Summer, is making some jokes. Jim calls. Pam says, I'm going to call you back
为了这场戏。女士，我正要说呢。就在你这么说的时候，我的脑海里涌现出一个回忆：一张巨大无比的长桌，他在上面用胶带划出了一个个小方格。对。每个方格里都放着一块处于不同腐烂阶段的水果。是的，全都是为了这个仅仅在镜头里出现两秒钟的笑点。我知道。又一次，剧本里某个无足轻重的一笔带过了的台词，催生了所有的这些制作。佛罗里达果蝇种植者协会、烂水果、果蝇驯养师。太不可思议了。镜头转换，来到普瑞特学院。帕姆在两节课之间的走廊里。她和新学校的朋友们打成一片。由里奇·萨莫饰演的亚历克斯开着玩笑。吉姆打来电话。帕姆说：我一会儿回你电话
because I made some friends. Okay. They were trying to make everybody mad. They were trying to make people feel like this art school thing might drive a wedge between Jim and Pam. Now, see, I wasn't worried yet. As I rewatch it, I'm not worried yet. I'm happy that she's making friends. I am too. I do want to say, Pam, what the F with your earrings? This is Sassy College Pam. She's got her updo ponytail. Did you look at the earrings though? They're like these purple roses. I mean, has this woman never dressed casually? I don't know. I feel like I'm celebrating Pam in this moment. You're really judging her whole outfit. I guess, you know, you don't have to be too worried about Pam attracting other men with those earrings on.
因为我交到朋友了。好的。他们当时在试图让所有人抓狂。他们试图让人觉得艺术学校这事可能会在吉姆和帕姆之间产生隔阂。你看，我当时可还没担心呢。当我重温时，我依然不担心。我很高兴她能交到朋友。我也是。我只想说，帕姆，你的耳环是怎么回事？这是个性十足的大学帕姆。她扎着高高的马尾辫。不过你看那个耳环了吗？就像是那种紫色的玫瑰。我的意思是，这个女人难道从来没有穿得休闲过吗？不知道。我觉得此刻我简直在为帕姆庆祝。你真是在对她的整套装扮评头论足啊。我猜，你知道的，戴着那种耳环，你倒是不必太担心帕姆会吸引别的男人了。
Oh, stop. I don't know. She looked cute. I have to take us back to the bullpen because at 27 minutes, 13 seconds, one of the best scenes of this episode is Phyllis storming in. She is ticked off. Jean Stipnitsky said this is his favorite scene of the episode. I loved it so much. I mean, Dwight drives Phyllis to an abandoned warehouse five miles away and kicks her out of the car. Yeah. He took her money and her phone. And so she had to walk back. And Dwight says, I bet you burned about a thousand calories. Phyllis is not having it. I think pissed off Phyllis is my favorite Phyllis. It's such a hard call because pissed off Phyllis is so great. But I do also love like emotionally wounded Phyllis. Like the whole thing that went
哦，得了吧。我不知道。她看起来挺可爱的。我得把大家带回办公区，因为在27分13秒，这一集中最棒的场景之一就是菲利斯气势汹汹地冲进来。她气炸了。让·斯特普尼斯基说这是他这一集中最喜欢的场景。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，德怀特把菲利斯载到一个五英里外的废弃仓库，然后把她赶下了车。对。他拿走了她的钱和手机。所以她不得不走回来。而德怀特说：我打赌你大概消耗了一千卡路里。菲利斯根本不吃这一套。我觉得生气的菲利斯是我最喜欢的菲利斯。这很难抉择，因为生气的菲利斯太棒了。但我其实也很喜欢那种情感受伤的菲利斯。就像整个那场发生在
down with Sue Grafton. Oh gosh, yes. At the steam town mall. Sue Grafton. That was so good too. Week six of The Way In. There is no way in this week. Holly instead reads an official statement from corporate. They're just concerned. You know, this was supposed to be about health and wellness and they need to make sure that everyone knows the point of this like health kick. In case the memo wasn't enough, Michael's going to try to help explain it. Oh yeah, Michael wants to bring it on home with one of his characters. This is how you get people's attention. Remember, as a little kid, Hoot the Owl came to his elementary school. If you want to get through to someone, you dress up as a character. So, enter Michael Klump.
蒸汽小镇购物中心的戏。苏·格拉夫顿。哦天哪，是的。苏·格拉夫顿。那段也太棒了。过称的第六周。这周没有过称。取而代之的是，霍莉宣读了一份来自总公司的官方声明。他们只是觉得担心。你知道的，这本该是关于健康和体能的，他们需要确保每个人都知道发起这种健康热潮的意义。万一备忘录还不够，迈克尔打算亲自出马用他的一个角色来解释。哦，是的，迈克尔想用他的人物形象把这个理念贯彻到底。这就是你如何吸引别人注意力的办法。记住，小时候，“猫头鹰胡特”曾去过他的小学。如果你想和一个人生交流，你就得扮成一个角色。所以，迈克尔·克伦普登场。
Yep. We had a fan question, Angela, from Grayeen L. When Michael says he's wearing his sumo suit from Beach Games, was Steve actually wearing his sumo suit underneath his clothes? No. So, here's the deal. Alicia, our wardrobe designer, was actually part of the DVD commentary and she said they weren't able to use the sumo suit. They had to buy a special type of suit that went under the sports jacket and pants and Steve actually had to have two pretty thorough fittings for this whole thing to happen. Wow. I bet Steve got hot. I wonder if they used his air conditioned vest that you told us about last week. His cooling vest. Yeah. Probably. Well, Michael is leading this whole meeting where he wants to celebrate people's body image no matter what you
没错。安吉拉，我们收到了一个来自格雷恩·L的粉丝提问。当迈克尔说他穿着来自《海滩运动会》的相扑服时，史蒂夫真的是在衣服里面穿着他的相扑服吗？并没有。所以情况是这样的。我们的服装设计师艾莉西亚实际上参与了DVD评论音轨的录音，她说他们没法使用那件相扑服。他们不得不买了一种特殊的服装穿在运动夹克和裤子里面，而且为了完成这一整套造型，史蒂夫实际上得经历两次非常彻底的试装。哇。我敢打赌史蒂夫当时肯定热坏了。我想知道他们有没有用你上周跟我们提到的那个带空调的背心。他的冷却背心。对。可能吧。好吧，迈克尔正在主持整个会议，他想要庆祝人们的身体形象，无论你
look like and during this meeting he looks over and he notices that Ryan has shaved his goatee. Yeah. And he's like, Ryan, did you shave your goatee? And Ryan's like, yeah, I did. Well, now all the goatees are going to come off. Well, yeah. You know, Michael is trying to get everyone to celebrate how their bodies are different but beautiful and Michael kneels down to talk to Kelly. You guys, 31 minutes, 21 seconds. Mindy is doing her classic covering her mouth so you can't see her starting to break. I noticed it too. I noticed it right away. Michael makes Kelly stand up. He wants everyone to look at her and tell her how great she looks. Ryan says she's perfect. Meredith likes her fingernails. Phyllis likes her dress and Creed says she has a hell of an ass. Yeah.
长成什么样，在这次会议期间，他看了一眼，发现瑞安刮掉了山羊胡。对。然后他说：瑞安，你把山羊胡刮了吗？瑞安说：对，我刮了。好吧，现在所有的山羊胡都得刮掉了。好吧。你知道的，迈克尔正试图让每个人都去庆祝自己与众不同但美丽的身躯，迈克尔跪下来和凯莉说话。伙计们，31分21秒。敏迪正在做她经典的捂住嘴巴的动作，这样你就看不到她开始笑场了。我也注意到了。我一眼就注意到了。迈克尔让凯莉站起来。他想让每个人都看着她，告诉她她看起来有多棒。瑞安说她很完美。梅雷迪思喜欢她的指甲。菲利斯喜欢她的裙子，而克里德说她有着迷人的屁股。对。
And Kelly's like, what else? I wasn't there. I was at art school. Yeah. It was such a bummer. There were a lot of things that I missed. These were the classic conference room scenes when you guys would be stuck in there for a whole day, maybe two. Oh, yes. We got pretty punchy in there. But one of my favorite talking heads is Phyllis saying she wonders what people would like about her. Probably her jugs. Maybe so. Speaking of art school, Pam's in class and Alex is making her giggle. Flirty, flirt. They even get in trouble. Well, I have a little fun fact. If you listen closely, you can hear her art school professor saying this. Some blame it on the new air conditioning system. This is what he's talking about. There are these paintings in France called the Lascaux
然后凯莉说：还有别的吗？我当时不在。我在艺术学校呢。对。真是太遗憾了。有很多事情我都错过了。这些都是经典的会议室场景，你们会被困在里面整整一天，甚至两天。哦，是的。我们在里面写得挺随性的。但其中一个我最喜欢的单人访谈是菲利斯说她不知道别人会喜欢她什么。大概是她的胸部吧。也许吧。说到艺术学校，帕姆正在上课，亚历克斯逗得她咯咯直笑。打情骂俏。他们甚至还惹麻烦了。好吧，我有一个有趣的冷知识。如果你仔细听，你能听到她的艺术学校教授说这样的话：有些人将其归咎于新的空调系统。这就是他在谈论的内容。法国有一些被称为拉斯科
paintings, if I'm pronouncing that correctly. They are ancient cave paintings and they have just faced incredible disturbance since their discovery because they have tourists come through. Like upwards of like 1200 tourists a day, they put in air conditioning in this cave, they put in lighting systems to make viewing these paintings more enjoyable. But as a result, lichens, I don't know if I'm pronouncing that correctly, but whatever lichens are and crystals they start to appear on the walls in the late 1950s and they had to close down these caves to preserve what was left of the sacred paintings. So when he says some blame it on the new air conditioning system, he's talking about these cave paintings in France. Well, that was a lot
壁画的画作，如果我发音正确的话。它们是古老的洞穴壁画，自从被发现以来，由于游客的涌入，它们一直面临着难以置信的破坏。就像每天有高达1200名游客一样，他们在山洞里安装了空调，安装了照明系统，使观赏这些画作更加愉快。但结果是，地衣，我不知道我发音是否正确，但不管地衣是什么，还有晶体，在20世纪50年代末开始出现在墙壁上，他们不得不关闭这些洞穴以保护残存的神圣画作。所以当他说有些人将其归咎于新的空调系统时，他指的是法国的这些洞穴壁画。好吧，这包含了很多
of good information. I just think it's really cool that our writers, someone is very, very smart on our writing staff. Yeah. Was it Jean? Was it Lee? Was it someone else? I don't know. Maybe it was Paul Lieberstein because we know he's quite the world traveler and likes art. Someone did a little digging and planted a little seed there. Yeah. Well, this scene, in juxtaposition to Jim's talking head, got people fired up because here's Pam laughing in art class with Alex. And then there's a Jim talking head. He says, summer's going great. Just listen to Michael clump for two hours, convinced I have an ulcer, and my girlfriend lives in New York and I haven't seen her in 10 days. So people were not happy with Pam when this episode aired. I remember.
有用的信息。我只是觉得很酷，我们的编剧，我们的编剧团队里一定有人非常非常聪明。对。是让吗？是李吗？还是别人？我不知道。也许是保罗·利伯斯坦，因为我们知道他是个十足的世界旅行者，而且喜欢艺术。有人做了一点功课，在那里埋下了伏笔。对。好吧，这个场景，与吉姆的单人访谈并置，让人们感到愤怒，因为这里是帕姆在艺术课上和亚历克斯一起大笑。然后是吉姆的单人访谈。他说：夏天过得很棒。只要听迈克尔·克伦普讲两个小时，确信我得了溃疡，我的女朋友住在纽约，而且我已经10天没见到她了。所以当这一集播出时，人们对帕姆很不满。我记得。
I have a lot to say. Oh, no. Oh, no. Well, I just want to say that when Pam went to art school for only three months when she was not yet married and didn't have children, people came down real hard on her because of Jim's feelings. Then when Jim invested in a business without telling Pam and left his family and left Pam alone to care for their two children while he chased his dreams, people came down on Pam again for not being supportive enough of Jim. So in both of these instances, I just want to say I noticed a lot of hate for Pam. Do I want to call it sexist? I do. I do. Oh, my gosh. I just want to say that Pam faced a lot of scrutiny as a character, I think because she was a woman, right? Yeah, that river runs deep. It runs deep,
我有太多话要说了。哦，不。哦，不。好吧，我只想说，当帕姆去上艺术学校仅仅三个月，当时她还没结婚也没有孩子时，人们因为吉姆的感受而对她严厉批判。后来，当吉姆在没有告诉帕姆的情况下投资了一项生意，抛下他的家庭，让帕姆独自照顾他们的两个孩子，而他自己去追逐梦想时，人们又因为帕姆对吉姆不够支持而再次批判了她。所以在所有这些情况下，我只想说我注意到有很多针对帕姆的仇恨。我想称之为厌女吗？我确实这么认为。我确实这么认为。哦，天哪。我只想说，帕姆作为角色的确面临了很多挑剔，我认为是因为她是个女人，对吧？对，这种偏见根深蒂固。它根深蒂固，
and it's going to run long into some future seasons. Okay. Should we take a break? We should because when we come back, we're going to have a weather breakdown. A weather breakdown? I can't wait. Well, we are back and it is pouring rain. There is a black screen with the words week seven, August 11th, and you can just hear the rain. Now it's time for the way in. Everyone's in the warehouse. The huge warehouse door is open and it's just coming down. I wonder why it needed to rain. I wonder why we needed to establish a big rainstorm, huh? I don't know. Maybe we'll find out in a little bit. Well, this was fake rain,
而且这种影响将延续到未来的好几个季度。好吧。我们要不要休息一下？我们得休息，因为当我们回来时，我们将迎来一场天气大剖析。天气大剖析？我迫不及待了。好吧，我们回来了，外面下着倾盆大雨。黑色的屏幕上写着第七周，8月11日，你只能听到雨声。现在到了过称的时间了。大家都在仓库里。巨大的仓库门开着，雨正哗啦啦地下着。我想知道为什么非得下雨呢。我想知道为什么我们需要设定一场大暴雨，是吧？我不知道。也许一会儿我们就知道了。好吧，这是人工降雨，
and yes, this was thought out. They wanted to establish this big rainstorm outside of the windows of our set in the bullpen where normally there would be the big backdrops, right, Jenna? Yep. They brought in those rain panels that you told us about. Oh, because we had an episode where Michael couldn't get the top up on his convertible, and then it rained inside the car. That's right. So they brought back in those big window panes that they were able to sort of recycle water through so it looked like raining, and you're going to see it in the backdrop of several scenes that just help keep reinforcing that it is a rainy day out. The one thing I will tell you is that sometimes with this rain outside the warehouse, they would have to adjust that for
而且是的，这是经过深思熟虑的。他们想在办公区布景的窗户外营造这场大暴雨，通常那里会有巨大的背景幕，对吧，詹娜？没错。他们搬来了你跟我们讲过的那种降雨板。哦，因为我们有一集讲的是迈克尔无法拉起敞篷车的车顶，然后车里下起了雨。没错。所以他们重新搬来了那些大型窗玻璃，可以通过循环水流让它看起来像在下雨，你会在几个场景的背景中看到它，这有助于不断强化外面是个雨天的感觉。我要告诉你的一件事是，有时由于仓库外面的雨声，剪辑部门的声音剪辑师必须对其进行调整，但他们说听起来很真实，所以声音部门不必剪掉人工降雨的声音。好吧。好吧，那就这样。另外，如果你在追剧，还记得凯莉·坎特利在上周的剧集里给我们列出了一份需要关注的清单吗？我们现在知道了：两个没山羊胡的家伙，一个有山羊胡的家伙。迈克尔和瑞安没胡子，德怀特留着山羊胡。没错。他们也迎来了第七周的过称，这时候霍莉说她已经有大约三天没听到她的瑜伽教练约会对象的消息了。对。她甚至买好了那天晚上数乌鸦乐队的票，她不知道，比如，他会露面吗？他会打电话吗？对。而达里尔宣布他们减掉了四磅。四磅。与此同时，回到
the sound department in editing, but they said it sounded real, so the sound department didn't have to edit out the fake rain. Huh. Well, there you go. Also, if you're keeping track, remember Kelly Cantley in last week's episode gave us a list of things to keep track of. We are now two guys, no goatee, one guy goatee. Michael and Ryan, no goatee, Dwight with a goatee. That's right. They're also having their week seven weigh-in, and this is when Holly says she hasn't heard from her yoga teacher date in like three days. Yeah. She had even bought tickets to the counting crows for that night, and she doesn't know, like, is he going to show? Is he going to call? Yeah. And Darrell announces that they've lost four pounds. Four pounds. Meanwhile, back in
剪辑时的音效部门，但他们说听起来很真实，所以音效部门不必把假雨声剪掉。哈。好吧，就是这样。另外，如果你一直在关注，记住上周的那集里凯利·坎特利给我们列出了一份需要关注的事项清单。我们现在是两个人没有山羊胡，一个人有山羊胡。迈克尔和瑞恩没有山羊胡，德怀特留着山羊胡。没错。他们也迎来了第七周的称重，这时霍莉说她已经大约三天没有收到她约会的瑜伽老师的消息了。是啊。她甚至买好了那天晚上“数乌鸦”乐队的门票，她不知道，比如，他会出现吗？他会打电话吗？是啊。达里尔宣布他们减掉了四磅。四磅。与此同时，回到了
the bullpen, Jim and Pam, they're chatting on IM. They're trying to figure out when can they see each other. Jim has a conflict with his nephew's ball game. You know, they don't know. Jim says, why don't you meet me for lunch? Yeah, kind of spontaneous. We'll meet in the middle. Yeah, meet halfway. Let's meet at the rest stop. That's halfway between New York and Scranton. When this whole time, Dwight thinks Jim is talking about him, right, that he's up to something. And Pam, IM's Jim and says, oh, by the way, finish my summer project. And Jim clicks on it. And guess what's there? A picture of Dwight. It is an ASCII portrait, which stands for American Standard Code for Information Interchange, which is a
办公区，吉姆和帕姆正在即时通讯上聊天。他们试图弄清楚什么时候能见面。吉姆和侄子的球赛时间冲突了。你知道的，他们拿不准。吉姆说：你为什么不来跟我一起吃午饭？对，有点随性。我们在中间碰头。对，在半路碰头。我们在服务区见面吧。那是纽约和斯克兰顿的正中间。而与此同时，德怀特以为吉姆在说他，对吧，觉得他在搞什么鬼。然后帕姆给吉姆发即时消息说：哦，对了，帮我完成夏天的作业吧。吉姆点击了它。你猜上面有什么？一张德怀特的照片。这是一个ASCII肖像，代表美国信息交换标准代码，它是
character encoding standard for electronic communication. ASCII codes represent text and computers, telecommunication equipment, and other devices. Well, guess who has a copy of it? Who? Joya. And she sent it to me. Oh, my gosh. So I have Pam's ASCII portrait of Dwight. I'll put it in our stories. I love that. Well, I like it because it shows that Pam is learning things in school. She's not just flirting. No, she's not, everyone. And we're taking it seriously. She's putting on her purple flower earrings and marching her ponytail into class. Holly goes in to talk to Michael and she wants him to know that they have lost Utica by only eight pounds. And Michael's like, wait a second. We have to the end of the day. Maybe if they really go for it,
电子通信的字符编码标准。ASCII代码代表计算机、电信设备和其他设备中的文本。好吧，你猜谁有一份复制品？谁？乔雅。她发给我的。哦，天哪。所以我拥有帕姆画的德怀特的ASCII肖像。我会把它发到我们的快拍里。我太喜欢了。好吧，我喜欢它，因为它表明帕姆在学校里学到了东西。她不只是在调情。不，她不是，各位。我们正在认真对待它。她戴上紫色的花朵耳环，扎着马尾辫大步走进课堂。霍莉进去和迈克尔说话，她想让他知道他们只比尤蒂卡少落后八磅。迈克尔却说：等一下。我们还有到今天结束的时间呢。也许如果他们真的拼一把，
they crank up the heat, they're going to wear trash bags. Maybe they can get there. Well, Andy's into it immediately. He puts on his trash bags. He says he does not lose competitions. He wins them or he quits because they're unfair. Kelly is not participating. She's having some pizza. The wedding planning has not stopped between Andy and Angela. Angela says, hey, she asks very nicely, by the way, if the first dance can be to Little Drummer Boy, her favorite song. Andy's like, yeah, he's already booked his acapella group. Oh, yeah. It's even better than can their last song be to Little Drummer Boy. His acapella group is going to sing it for you. Yeah. Here comes trouble class of 96. And he's like, sweetheart, you're going to
他们把暖气调得很高，还套着垃圾袋。也许他们能行。安迪立刻就加入了。他套上垃圾袋。他说他从不输比赛。他要么赢，要么因为比赛不公而退出。凯莉没有参与。她在吃披萨。安迪和安吉拉的婚礼筹备一直在继续。安吉拉说，顺便问一下，她非常客气地请求第一支舞能不能放《小鼓手男孩》，那是她最喜欢的歌。安迪一口答应，说他已经订好阿卡贝拉乐队了。哦，对啊。甚至更好，不仅是第一支舞能用《小鼓手男孩》，他的阿卡贝拉乐队会亲自为你演唱。耶。96届的麻烦制造者来了。安迪对她说，亲爱的，你一定会
love these guys. Carl one, Carl two, broccoli, Rob, spare rib, doobie, lunchbox, boner champ, that's me. Pewdie Lewis in the news, hopscotch, jingle jangle and sandwich. Yeah. And they're collectively going to be his best man. Yeah. Guess who's paging Dwight. Oh, yeah. Now, if I remember correctly, Angela, NBC built a website for Andy and Angela's wedding. Do you remember that? It's not live anymore. But do you remember that? I do. And I asked Joy about it. She sent me the homepage photo of Angela and Andy's wedding website, complete with their wedding gift registry and the audition video that Andy put together of Here Comes Trouble to be their wedding band. Wow. I have all of it. I'll put it in stories. I have all of it. And I want to read to you,
爱死这群家伙的。卡尔一号、卡尔二号、西兰花罗布、排骨、杜比、饭盒、小呆瓜，就是我。新闻里的皮迪·刘易斯、跳房子、叮当响和三明治。耶。他们将共同担任他的伴伴郎。耶。你猜谁在寻呼德 Dwight。哦，耶。现在，如果我没记错的话，安吉拉，NBC为安迪和安吉拉的婚礼搭建了一个网站。你还记得吗？现在已经无法访问了。但你还记得吗？我记得。我问过乔伊这件事。她发给我安迪和安吉拉婚礼网站的主页照片，上面不仅有他们的结婚礼物登记表，还有安迪制作的、由“麻烦制造者”乐队试镜的视频，他们想成为婚礼乐队。哇。我全都有。我会发到快拍里。我全都有。我想读给你听，
though, the items on the registry, please. So Joy has said the joke was that Andy would list something and then Angela would list something in stark opposition to what Andy had listed. Okay. So see if you can guess who put what on the registry. The singing machine ISM370 karaoke with iPod dock. Noise canceling headphones. Twilight thick, non see-through shower curtain. Deadbolt bathroom door lock. Modesty changing screen. His and hers kitty cat PJs, kids small and men size large. Kitty cat Shay's lounge. Three Cornell big red ultimate outdoor rugs. Marie Osmond inspiration bench. Decorative wall hat and Getty's calendar. Wow. That's what was on the registry on the NBC.com wedding site.
不过，登记表上的物品，请吧。乔伊说，这里的笑话是，安迪列出一件东西，然后安吉拉就会列出一件与安迪所列东西完全相反的东西。好吧。所以看看你能不能猜出谁在登记表上放了什么。ISM370卡拉OK歌唱机带iPod底座。降噪耳机。暮光之城厚实不透明浴帘。浴室门死锁。简易更衣屏风。情侣猫咪睡衣，儿童小号和大号男装。猫咪躺椅。三张康奈尔红大高地户外地毯。玛丽·奥斯蒙德灵感长凳。装饰性壁挂帽和盖蒂日历。哇。这就是NBC.com婚礼网站上登记的东西。
It's time. It's time. Jim and Pam, they're going to meet up at the rest stop. In the pouring rain, we have a lot to share about it. Jenna, you were there. I was not. I have some fantastic DVD commentary stuff to share with you from our crew, but you should take it away. Well, this is the proposal scene. Yes. Jim gets down on one knee and he proposes to Pam. She's totally shocked. They're at a gas station. You know, he was supposed to wait till she got back from art school, but he says he couldn't wait. She's completely thrown. Yeah. You can really tell she had no idea. In fact, the beginning of the scene, she's like, Hey, this is not halfway. I drove further. Her head is so not in that place. Yeah. But she says yes, and they kiss.
时候到了。时候到了。吉姆和帕姆，他们要在服务区碰面。在倾盆大雨中，我们有很多事情要分享。珍娜，你当时在场。我不在。我有一些来自我们剧组的精彩DVD评论内容要和你分享，不过你先说吧。好吧，这就是求婚场景。是的。吉姆单膝下跪向帕姆求婚。她完全惊呆了。他们在一个加油站。你知道的，他本该等她艺术学校回来再求婚，但他说他等不及了。她完全不知所措。是的。你真的能看出她完全没想到。事实上，在场景一开始，她说，嘿，这根本不到一半啊。我开得更远。她的心思根本不在那上面。是的。但她答应了，然后他们亲吻了。
So first of all, I just want you guys to know that Greg spoke with us about this. He said that he really wanted Jim's proposal to Pam to be in the season premiere. He thought, number one, that would be unexpected. You usually end seasons with proposals. Right. So he thought this would be a real shock. And it was, Jenna, I even remember at the table read, you know, we had so much going on with this weight loss story and Pam at art school. I didn't see it coming. No. And we've been teasing it all last season. He said he also wanted to throw people off by having it in a very ordinary location. So he wanted to feel special, but he also wanted it to feel like Jim made the decision
所以首先，我想让大家知道，格雷格和我们谈过这件事。他说他真的很想让吉姆向帕姆的求婚出现在季首集里。他认为，第一，这会出乎意料。你通常在季终集求婚。对吧。所以他觉得这会是一个真正的震撼。确实如此，珍娜，我甚至还记得在剧本围读时，你知道的，我们有减肥故事和帕姆在艺术学校，事情太多了。我根本没料到。没有。而且我们整个上一季都在铺垫。他说他还想通过在一个非常普通的地点来打乱人们的预期。所以他希望它感觉很特别，但也希望它感觉像是吉姆做出的决定，
without a whole lot of planning. So Greg thought that the ideal location for this scene would be a gas station along the freeway between Scranton and New York in the rain. And they based the rest stop on one that Greg Daniels had traveled to as a kid along the Merritt Parkway. We did not actually fly to this location. This is the insane part. They built this in the parking lot of a Best Buy that I have been to many times actually. What they did was they used Google Street View to capture images of a real gas station along the Merritt Parkway. And then using those images, they built it to match in this parking lot. It took them about nine days to build it to create the illusion of highway traffic. They built a
并没有经过太多的筹划。所以格雷格认为这个场景的理想地点是斯克兰顿和纽约之间高速公路旁的一个雨中加油站。他们把这个休息区设在格雷格·丹尼尔斯小时候沿着梅里特公园大道去过的一个休息区。我们实际上并没有飞到那个地方。这才是最疯狂的部分。他们是在百思买的停车场搭建的这个场景，我其实去过很多次。他们的做法是使用谷歌街景捕捉梅里特公园大道上真实加油站的图像。然后利用这些图像，在这个停车场里搭建了一个一模一样的。他们花了大约九天时间来搭建，为了营造高速公路车流的幻觉，他们搭建了一个
four-lane circular race track around the gas station set. They set up cameras on the other side of this raceway, and they had cars drive around it at 55 miles an hour. Then they added rain pouring down on us, these giant rain machines. Our production manager, Randy Cordray, said they had about 35 precision drivers. They were driving not just cars, but like semi-trucks. Mm-hmm. When we were standing there on that set, you could feel the wind like of these cars speeding past you. It was so, so bonkers. But after we shot the scene, they had to hire a special effects company to paint out the background because the background were these California mountains. Mm-hmm. And so they had to paint out the mountains and put in
环绕加油站布景的四车道环形赛道。他们在赛道的另一边架设了摄像机，让车辆以每小时55英里的速度绕着它开。然后他们加上了倾盆大雨，就是那些巨大的造雨机。我们的制片经理兰迪·科德雷说，他们大约有35名精准驾驶员。他们开的不仅是轿车，还有半挂卡车。嗯哼。当我们站在那个布景里时，你能感觉到这些车从你身边疾驰而过的风。太疯狂了，真的是太疯狂了。但在我们拍摄完这个场景后，他们不得不聘请一家特效公司把背景涂掉，因为背景是加州的群山。嗯哼。所以他们不得不把群山涂掉，换上
some trees like east coast-looking trees. In the end, this was the single most expensive scene ever shot during the entire run of the show. It lasts 52 seconds, and it costs $250,000. Oh, my Lord. Oh, my Lord. Wow. Yeah. So a quarter of a million dollars for less than one minute of screen time. Oh, my gosh. Well, listen, they talked in depth, our crew, about this moment in the DVD commentary. Several obviously very similar things as what you just shared. So after months and months of scouting and meetings, it was our location manager, Kyle Alexander, who found this enormous paved parking lot. I guess it was off Los Feliz Boulevard. Yep. Acres and acres of paved ground, which is what they needed if they were going to build a racetrack basically, right? Yeah.
一些像东海岸那样的树木。最后，这是整部剧播出期间拍摄过的单场最贵的戏。它持续了52秒，花费了25万美元。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哇。是的，四分之一百万美元只换来不到一分钟的荧幕时间。哦，天哪。好吧，听着，我们的剧组在DVD评论中深入讨论了这一刻。显然有几个非常类似于你刚才分享的内容。所以在经历了几个月的勘景和会议后，是我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大找到了这个巨大的铺面停车场。我猜它在洛斯费利斯大道附近吧。是的。成亩成亩的铺砌地面，如果他们基本上要建造一个赛车场的话，这正是他们所需要的，对吧？是的。
So these cars could loop around. Now, according to Randy Cordray, the reason why it was such a massive, massive, massive parking lot is because it was a paved over toxic waste site. What? Yes. Apparently years and years and years ago, there was an old like ceramics plant or something that had buried lead paint waste into the ground. So they had to seal it and cover it. So Angela, I just want to make sure that we acknowledge that the information you've just given us means that Jim and Pam, our beloved jam, got engaged at a former toxic waste dump. fluorescent jam. I mean, Yikesie. Well, this is what they shared in the DVD commentary. It was a long time ago. They sealed it up. It's a giant parking lot. Apparently there's a best buy there
所以这些车可以绕圈开。现在，根据兰迪·科德雷的说法，为什么它会是一个如此巨大、巨大、巨大的停车场，因为它是一个铺平的有毒废弃物场。什么？是的。显然在很多很多很多年以前，那里有一个旧的陶瓷厂之类的东西，把含铅油漆废物埋在了地下。所以他们必须封锁并覆盖它。所以安吉拉，我只是想确保我们承认你刚才给我们的信息意味着吉姆和帕姆，我们深爱的果酱，在一个以前的有毒废弃物倾倒场订婚了。荧光果酱。我的天啊。好吧，这就是他们在DVD评论中分享的内容。那是很久以前的事了。他们把它封起来了。这是一个巨大的停车场。显然现在那里有一家百思买。
now. Michael Gallenberg shares on the DVD commentary, one of his favorite things that he built of this whole set was the drinks behind the glass doors. It's in fact one humongous giant photo. It was an inkjet print on foam core paper. It looks amazing. And there's a great shot at 38 minutes, 32 seconds right behind Jim and Pam. I would have never known that those drinks were a photo. Yeah, it was an incredible set. Yeah, really just kudos to our set design team and our construction guys. They just crushed it. It was incredible. The one other debate about the scene, which I'm sure you know, was whether to have sound or no sound. This was a huge, huge debate. Greg could not make up his mind. They had two versions ready to go, one with sound during the proposal and one
迈克尔·盖伦伯格在DVD评论中分享说，整个布景中他最喜欢建造的东西之一就是玻璃门后面的饮料。它其实是一个巨大的照片。它是泡沫芯纸上的喷墨打印件。看起来太棒了。在38分32秒处有一个很棒的镜头，就在吉姆和帕姆身后。我永远不会知道那些饮料只是一张照片。是的，这是一个不可思议的布景。是的，真的要向我们的布景设计团队和施工人员致敬。他们太棒了。不可思议。关于这个场景的另一个争论，我确信你知道的，就是该有声音还是没有声音。这是一个非常非常巨大的争论。格雷格拿不定主意。他们准备好了两个版本，一个在求婚期间有声音，一个
without. And literally, I mean, Jake shared on the DVD commentary, Jake oust, that up until the day of airing, it was the air date, Greg was still trying to decide. It's so funny because I vaguely remember that. But we spoke dialogue every time. So the debate was just simply whether Jim and Pam were still wearing their microphones and you could hear our dialogue or Jim and Pam weren't wearing their microphones and you couldn't. So we said dialogue every time. It wasn't like there were two different scenes that were written with or without dialogue. It was just whether or not you could hear it. Yeah. I don't think John and I knew about this big debate because we were just saying our lines every time. Yeah. I liked being able to hear it. I think it was important that you
没有。真的，我的意思是杰克在DVD评论中分享过，杰克·奥斯特，直到播出当天，也就是播出日，格雷格还在试图做决定。太搞笑了，因为我隐约记得这件事。但我们每次都有念台词。所以争论仅仅在于吉姆和帕姆是否还戴着麦克风，你能听到我们的对话，或者吉姆和帕姆没戴麦克风，你听不到。所以我们每次都念台词。并不是写了两个不同的场景，一个有台词一个没有。只是关于你能听见还是听不见。是的。我想约翰和我当时并不知道这个大争论，因为我们每次都在念台词。是的。我喜欢能听到声音。我认为你能听到它
heard it. Yeah. I have a few more things to share that hopefully won't shatter your memories of this moment. Like you said, the trees were digitally put back in, right? They are East Coast trees. They were put in digitally by Stargate. And here was the other thing that was a big, big question mark about how they do this, was the rain. How do they do the rain? And they really considered doing it digitally, adding it in post-production, but Paul Feig was very, very against it. He wanted the rain to feel as real as possible. And we could feel the rain. I mean, there were, you know, it was, I don't know if it was just the wind from the cars. I don't remember there being wind machines, but I do remember the rain
很重要。是的。我还有一些事情要分享，希望不会粉碎你对这一刻的记忆。就像你说的，树木是通过数字技术重新加进去的，对吧？它们是东海岸的树木。它们是由星门公司通过数字技术加进去的。这里还有另一件关于他们如何做到这一点的大大问号的事情，就是雨。他们是怎么造雨的？他们确实考虑过用数字方式来做，在后期制作中添加，但保罗·费格非常非常反对。他希望雨感觉尽可能真实。我们能感觉到雨。我的意思是，有，你知道的，这，我不知道是不是车风造成的。我不记得有什么风机，但我确实记得雨
hitting us. And I mean, even though it was a former toxic waste dump and even though it was a Best Buy parking lot. Yeah. Just like it was actually to be there, really romantic. You know, it was funny. The gas station, it was just up front. If you went in, it was like a fakey-fake. You go through the door and then you're just like looking at trees. It didn't have a back or anything. Yeah. But it felt magical. It did. And it was so much fun to shoot that scene. I mean, I feel like we got it on the first take. And maybe we did a few. But my memory is that we weren't there long, that we got it pretty early. And it was a cool moment. It's a really magical moment. Well, when the gang is ready to weigh in again, Jim is late. And then he shows up soaking wet.
打在我们身上。我的意思是，尽管它曾经是一个有毒废物倾倒场，尽管它是一个百思买停车场。是的。就像身临其境一样，真的很浪漫。你知道，这很有趣。加油站就在正前方。如果你走进去，它就像是个假的。你穿过门，然后你就像是在看着树木。它没有背面什么的。是的。但它感觉很神奇。确实如此。拍那个场景太有趣了。我的意思是，我觉得我们在第一个镜头就拍好了。也许我们拍了几个。但我的记忆是我们在那儿待的时间不长，我们很早就拍好了。这是一个很酷的时刻。这是一个非常神奇的时刻。好吧，当大家准备再次发表意见时，吉姆迟到了。然后他浑身湿透地出现了。
And so happy. So happy. I was a little sad that they didn't get to spend the whole evening together after getting engaged. I guess Pam just had to drive back to school. I know. But Jim is so happy. Holly decides that this yoga guy is never going to call her. And Michael says, you know what, I'll buy the counting crows tickets from you. And she's like, really? Everybody thinks this is like going to lead to Michael offering to go with her? I thought they were going to have a date. No, Michael rips up the tickets like gallantly, like he's saving the day. She's confused. We got some mail from Emily G. Okay, here's what she said. Having worked at several concert venues, I wanted to let you know that if you lose or damage your concert tickets,
而且那么高兴。那么高兴。我有点难过他们在订婚后没有一起度过整个晚上。我猜帕姆不得不开车回学校。我知道。但吉姆太高兴了。霍莉决定这个瑜伽男永远不会给她打电话。迈克尔说，你知道吗，我从你那儿买乌鸦乐队的门票。她说，真的吗？每个人都觉得这会导致迈克尔主动提出和她一起去？我以为他们要约会了。不，迈克尔像英雄一样撕掉了门票，就像他在拯救世界一样。她很困惑。我们收到了来自艾米莉·G的一封邮件。好吧，她是这么说的。曾在几个音乐会场地工作过，我想告诉你们，如果你丢失或损坏了音乐会门票，
you can go to a venue's box office with your photo ID and someone will reprint them for you. Oh, she said, I hope Holly knew that was an option. Oh, that's good to know. Yeah, it didn't seem like Holly knew. No, I didn't know. Well, now we all know. Now we all know. Thank you, Emily. Yeah. In the end, Dunder Mifflin did not win the weight loss competition. Stanley lost seven pounds. Yeah, he says he's going to take off five days anyway. Yeah. And now it's week eight. Toby is on his fifth week in a hospital room in Costa Rica. Oh, poor Toby guys, remember? Toby had his weird moment with Pam, so he moved to Costa Rica. And on like his first day or day, was it like day three? Day three. Day three, he went ziplining and he broke his neck. Yeah. He
你可以带上带照片的身份证件去场地的售票处，有人会为你重新打印。哦，她说，希望霍莉知道还有这个选择。哦，那这就好办了。是的，霍莉好像并不知道。不，我不知道。好吧，现在我们都知道了。现在我们都知道了。谢谢你，艾米莉。是的。最后，邓德米夫林没有赢得减肥比赛。斯坦利瘦了七磅。是的，反正他说他要请假五天。是的。现在是第八周。托比在哥斯达黎加的一间病房里度过了他的第五周。哦，可怜的托比，大家还记得吗？托比对帕姆做出了一些奇怪的举动，所以他搬到了哥斯达黎加。然后在他第一天还是哪天，是第三天吗？第三天。第三天，他去玩了滑索，然后摔断了颈椎。是的。他
hasn't even been to the beach. Did you notice what was playing on the TV in the hospital room? Yes, I did. It is the hug it out bitch episode of entourage. That is the episode of entourage that Michael quotes in the coup. Well, I have a little location breakdown for you about Toby's hospital room. Give it to me. It was also filmed at USC. Oh, yeah. While they were there filming Pam's art school, they used the USC television stage building and USC asked if eight of their film students could intern and help that day. They had interns in all of the different departments and our crew said they did a phenomenal job. That is so cool. Before we go, I just want to give a shout out to whoever the guy is in the bed next to Toby. He was a background performer. Angela,
甚至还没去过海滩。你注意到病房里的电视在放什么了吗？是的，我注意到了。那是《明星伙伴》里“抱一个，碧池”那一集。那是迈克尔在《政变》里引用的《明星伙伴》那一集。好吧，我有一个关于托比病房的小外景解析要讲给你听。快告诉我。它也是在南加州大学拍摄的。哦，是的。当他们在那里拍摄帕姆的艺术学校时，他们使用了南加州大学的电视舞台大楼，南加州大学询问是否有八名电影专业的学生可以在那天实习并提供帮助。他们在所有不同的部门都有实习生，我们的剧组说他们做得非常出色。太酷了。在我们离开之前，我只想向躺在托比旁边床上的那个家伙致敬。他是一个背景演员，安吉拉，
I tried so hard to figure out who this is because he is so funny. He just stares into the camera the whole time Toby is talking. It is so good. I watched it three times. I was like, how is this guy doing such a great job with no words? I was so impressed. We couldn't figure out who he was. We reached out to several people. Yes. And I checked everywhere you can check. He is uncredited in the episode. Phenomenal job. Way to crush it. That was a weight loss part two. There are so many folks to thank for helping us get this episode out to you. First of all, our crew that participated in the DVD commentary, Randy Cordray, Michael Gallenberg, Brian Whittle, Nick Carbone, Ben Patrick, Alicia Raycraft, Kelly Cantley, and Jake Oust. Amazing. Best commentary.
我费了好大劲才弄清楚这人是谁，因为他太搞笑了。在托比说话的整个过程中，他一直盯着镜头看。太棒了。我看了三遍。我想，这个人没有台词怎么能演得这么好？我印象太深刻了。我们没能弄清楚他是谁。我们联系了好几个人。是的。我查了所有能查的地方。他在这一集里没有署名。表现太棒了。真是不负众望。那是减肥第二集。有太多人需要感谢，感谢他们帮助我们把这一集呈现给大家。首先，参与DVD评论的我们的剧组人员，兰迪·科德雷、迈克尔·盖伦伯格、布莱恩·惠特尔、尼克·卡尔博尼、本·帕特里克、艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫特、凯莉·坎特利和杰克·奥斯特。太棒了。最好的评论。
Really such a good listen if you love behind the scenes information. And James O'Carry for letting us bug you with questions. Yeah, we did. We did bug him. We did enjoy a Balfour. Oh my gosh, I'm so excited to share all of that NBC.com website stuff about Angela and Andy. And then Greg Daniels. Yes. Thank you. And also Paul Feig for that audio clip. I promise not to bother you too much, Paul Feig. Well, we probably will. I know. Why am I making that promise? But we appreciate our cast and crew so much. We hope you enjoyed this one. And we are kicking off season five. We'll be back for more next week. We sure will. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive
如果你喜欢幕后信息，这真的很值得一听。还有詹姆斯·奥凯利，感谢你让我们用问题打扰你。是的，我们确实打扰他了。我们确实享受了一次巴尔福。哦天哪，我很高兴能分享所有关于安吉拉和安迪的NBC.com网站的内容。还有格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的。谢谢你。还有保罗·费格提供的那个音频片段。我保证不会太打扰你，保罗·费格。好吧，我们大概还是会的。我知道。我为什么要做出那个承诺？但我们非常感谢我们的演员和剧组。希望你们喜欢这一集。我们将开启第五季。我们下周会回来带来更多内容。我们一定会回来的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目执行
produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用StitcherPremium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。目前这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。